S
"ONE NATION."
HERSCHEL WALKER, A LOT OF
PRESSURE ON HIS SHOULDERS.
THE MID-TERM ELECTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT.
THE FIRST OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO LOOK AT THEIR
CHIEF EXECUTIVE AND LET THEM
KNOW WHAT THEY THINK OF HIS
POLICIES WIN OR LOSE.
THEY GIVE A CLEAR PICTURE WHAT
VOTERS WANT.
A FORMULA FOR REELECTION AND A
CHANCE TO CHANGE BEFORE IT'S TOO
LATE.
THAT'S WHY I FIND IT NOTEWORTHY
AND SCARY THAT THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES WHO NARROWLY
AVOIDED A RED WAVE BUT NOT A
SHIFT IN POWER HAS NO PLANS FOR
CHANGE.
>> WHAT WOULD YOU DO DIFFERENTLY
TO CHANGE PEOPLE'S OPINION OF
THE DIRECTION OF THE COUNTRY?
>> NOTHING.
BECAUSE THEY ARE JUST FINDING
OUT WHAT WE ARE DOING.
THE MORE THEY FIND OUT ABOUT
WHAT WE ARE DOING, THE MORE
SUPPORT THERE IS.
BRIAN: BIDEN HAS NO PLANS TO
BRING DOWN INFLATION OR REIN IN
VIOLENT CRIME OR FIX THIS
COUNTRY'S BORDERS.
ONLY 25% OF THE COUNTRY THINKS
WE ARE HEADING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
THIS HASN'T ALWAYS BEEN THE WAY.
WHEN THE MID-TERM ELECTIONS
DIDN'T GOAT WAY OF THE PARTY IN
POWER OR A POLICY WAS FAILING,
CHANGES WERE MADE.
IT WASN'T A BIG DEAL.
FDR'S OVERREACH COST HIS PARTY
THE MID-TERMS.
PACKING THE COURT AND A NEW, NEW
DEAL.
AFTER LOSING 81 SEATS IN THE
HOUSE IN THAT ELECTION FDR
CHANGED HIS TUNE WORKING WITH
CONGRESS AND BUILDING UP HIS
DEMOCRATIC BASE.
JOE PLANS ON SINGING THE SAME
TUNE UNTIL 2024.
WHY?
HARRY S. TRUMAN WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO FOCUS ON ISSUES
IMPORTANT TO THIS PEOPLE.
CIVIL RIGHTS AND HEALTHCARE.
HE CHANGED.
WHAT MATTERS TO THE PEOPLE
DOESN'T SEEM TO MATTER TO JOE
BIDEN.
THERE WAS NO RED WAVE.
JFK, FOR EXAMPLE LEARNED FROM
THE BAY OF PIGS INVASION.
HE RECONFIGURED HIS STAFF AND
DECISION MAKING PROCESS.
AND WHEN THE SOVIET UNION FACED
HIM IN CUBA, HE STARED DOWN
KHRUSHCHEV.
HAS JOE BIDEN REESTABLISHED HIS
FOREIGN POLICY TEAM?
NO.
I DON'T THINK HE LEARNED FROM
HIS FOREIGN POLICY MISTAKES IN
AFGHANISTAN.
HE WILL NOT CHANGE.
I WILL GIVE YOU ANOTHER EXAMPLE.
1994, BILL CLINTON'S EMPTY
PROMISES AND SCANDALS CAUSED HIM
A LOST IN THE MID-TERMS.
HE REFOCUSED ONLY CRIME AND
WELFARE REFORM.
HE WORKED WITH REPUBLICANS AND
THE BUDGET WAS A FOCUS.
DO YOU KNOW HE BALANCED THE
BUDGET?
IT ACTUALLY WAS AT ZERO.
BIDEN FEELS NO NEED TO CHANGE,
EVEN AFTER ALL THOSE EXAMPLES HE
PROBABLY LIVED THROUGH.
2006, HURRICANE KATRINA, THE
DRAWN OUT IRAQ WAR WAS HURTING
PRESIDENT BUSH AND THE GOP.
AFTER THE MID-TERMS WHEN HE GOT
HAMMERED, GEORGE W. BUSH CHANGED
THINGS THINGS.
HE GOT RID OF HIS CHIEF STAFF
ANDY CARD.
DONALD RUMSFELD WAS FILED, THE
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE.
BUSH LISTENED TO THE ELECTORATE.
THERE IS NO PROBLEM WITH THAT IN
THE PAST.
THERE SEEMS TO BE NO LEADERSHIP
CHANGES IN THE PIPELINE FOR THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
THE YEAR WAS 2010.
BARACK OBAMA TOOK FULL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
SHELLACKING HIS PARTY ENDURED
DURING THE MID TERMS.
HE UNITED HIS PARTY AND SAILED
TO REELECTION IN 201